what's up hustle ambassadors instead of
writing an email today i'm feeling a
little lazy so instead i'm just going to
give you a little tour of our office
ready
all right
we decided to move in to this house i
gotta wait for these cars across this
house instead of an office because we
thought it was a little more exciting
so let's go inside
okay up the stairs
here's our sticker
if you have one
or you don't have one let me know we'll
send you one
there's the office history
see eva wave oh okay
they're we're doing some reorganizing
so the chairs are all over the place
jackie say hi hi
here's our new conference room that
we're still reorganizing
stickers everywhere
i don't feel like writing an email so
i'm just going to send a video
here's kendall he's writing the emails
that you read
this is going to the hustle ambassadors
oh what's up
they're still doing gross stuff hold on
here's our editorial calendar can't see
that there's intern kyle say hi kyle
just say hi hi that's good
and here we are
we just got this new setup
so there it is this is your
hustle ambassador email for the day
peace